satellite images appear to confirm
rehearsals have been taking place for a
major set-piece parade Pyongyang is used
to such events and the next is expected
to be held after an unprecedented series
of about 80 ballistic missile launches
in 2022 leader Kim Jong-un seems as
determined as ever to develop longer
range InterContinental missiles while
also acquiring an arsenal of shorter
range tactical weapons that threaten his
neighbors including South Korea and they
want to show the world across the Korea
and U.S that their tactical nuclear
capability is real and it can operate in
any situation The increased threat has
led the U.S to renew assurances to South
Korea that it will use its nuclear
umbrella to protect the country but it's
also raised the question of whether soul
itself should become nuclear armed amid
the escalating tensions North Korea has
stopped short of conducting another
nuclear test that was widely anticipated
throughout 2022 that it seems would have
been a provocation too far especially
for powerful neighbor China shortages of
food and other goods made worse by
self-imposed isolation through the
pandemic means North Korea is more
Reliant than ever on Chinese Aid
the only way for North Korea to overcome
the pandemic and its economic crisis is
to get more support from China so for
Kim Jong-un the threat of a seventh
nuclear test is very important leverage
that he can use
in December North Korea flew drones into
South Korea leading to speculation the
north could conduct other types of
attacks in the coming year to undermine
the South there's a whole lot of cities
of provocation North Korea can do
including the cyber attacks and you know
other you know
cognitive low pair to you know shaken
the Korean public North Korea seemingly
intent on another year of defiant
military posturing and the South
preparing to deal with the consequences
Rob McBride Al Jazeera Seoul